Traditional Korean Sports.
Though not a sport, various forms of Korean folk dancing are physically very demanding.
Kite flying is an East Asian sport...
...and traditional Korean paper kites are flown during Lunar New Year and Chuseok.
Bull fighting (Cheongdo so ssa-eum) in Korea...
...features two bulls fighting each other.
The bulls butt heads with the first bull to move backwards losing the contest.
Korean wrestling (ssirum) is similar to Japanese sumo wrestling.
Ssirum is done in a sandy ring,...
...with the wrestler who throws his opponent to the ground winning.
Modern Sports.
Five martial arts are popular:...
Taekwondo, Taekkyeon, Hapkido, Judo and Kumdo (Kendo).
Professional sports are dominated by baseball, soccer, and basketball...
...which are well developed with professional teams and foreign players.
Korea has world-class badminton players.
Bowling and tennis are popular recreational sports with many local leagues.
In winter, Korea host good downhill skiing and snowboarding slopes.
Golf is also very popular and is considered a high status sport.
Club membership is considerably cheaper than in Japan or the U.S.,...
...making golf even more popular.
Inline skating, skateboarding, and even the fantastic...
...moves of Korean hip-hop dancers are popular with teens.
Outdoor pastimes including...
...fishing, hiking, jogging with scuba diving popular on Jeju.
While table tennis, billiards, and pocket ball are popular indoor sports.
Finally, dancesports have become a reputable and popular recreation activity, too.